you know what i would have done and i
would have been excited and i would have
done
i would have worked
any hours to do
um was do eastbound and down and this
guy tested for it against me and i read
with danny and they said it's between
you and one other guy and they went with
you oh was it me yeah
and i go well [ __ ] i love ken but that
[ __ ] that's the one i wanted i
remember going in sorry about that no
but i remember you know and we hit it
off and um he came up to me at a table
read for something else he goes man you
were [ __ ] funny we were going to cast
you but you were right up there man you
were right up there with that with the
guy i go yeah candy's like yeah ken's
great but you were right up there too
just want you to know you were really
funny and he was cool so that's always
nice to hear that yes what a treat did
you improvise the [ __ ] out of that
there i mean you know they had a script
but yeah every scene
was
uh
you know they opened we opened it up i
think i mean i
definitely threw in a lot of stuff can
that be intimidating
working with someone like danny mcbride
i mean you go in toe to toe with him and
you did it and you nailed it but like
he's a he's a wizard right yeah he's
incredible he just goes were you just
shot like how funny was he on his side
always funny but always grounded oh he's
real like he never says anything that
doesn't feel like it's you know just
going back to the drama and the comedy
like
he's saying you know what when he would
say it it was you know grounded and real
and
and yeah it was funny but it was it
can't you know felt
it felt uh
like sure this it was
there was comedy in to it but it was
um real how always seems real how often
did you break
i don't remember because i think mcbride
is honestly one of my top favorite
comedians he's the best like i just like
it just i don't know how i would like i
mean i guess when you're on set you just
gotta stay in
it seems like you've done worked around
so many you've been
you hear that was that yeah that was
weird no oh what's gone now oh was it an
earthquake what do we got
but there's maybe it's your stomach
i didn't hear at that time but maybe but
you've worked with so many great
comedians you've been around them you've
you've worked with everybody a ton of
top-notch improvisational comedians so
there's probably not a lot that makes
you laugh anymore you seem like someone
that just was staying character and
you're hard to break is that something
is that true
i don't i don't think i break a lot no
i don't think i break a lot
i think you break when you're not
when you're not fully
the person that you're doing
i think like when you're watching
yourself you you break more than when
you when you're
really connected to the person because
whatever the person says
you know uh you should try to respond to
it in a in a real way through that
character that you're playing but you
know sometimes
something you know i i i can't always
get to that place so yeah i guess i
break sometimes
i don't know but don't you like it don't
you like it when you break every once in
a while i like watching other people
break i've i've been watching um a lot
of bloopers of uh always sunny
and my god first of all i love those
guys and i think that their show is i
had fun i got to do an episode i really
enjoyed it oh what did you do i did um
gun control it was like the first season
i was i played um her uh boyfriend
what's her name d d yeah dee's boyfriend
who comes into town it's yeah that's
really fun i mean you know watching them
and watching watching
them break each other up is
it it's like it's like a
it keeps coming up on my tick tock
and i'm like oh great give me more give
me more bloopers of them so you like
seeing other people [ __ ] up i like
seeing other people enjoy
each other and laugh